Ken: Oh- oh shit! Jack!
Mark: Wow!
[game] *puff*
All: *laughs*
Jack: Yey!
Mark: Jack!
Mark: I'm a red daddy
Mark: Red daddy is comin' in
Jack: R-right face button it is
Felix: Oh I like-
Ken: Oh daddy!
Mark: Hey daddy!
Mark: Daddy want some wrestler
Mark: Hey guys!
Mark: Hey why won't you come with daddy over here
Jack: NO! GOD ALMIGHTY!
Mark: *laughs*
Jack: NOOO GOD ALMIGHTY!
Ken: Aw you've saved him!
Ken: Yey!
Jack: Yeah, fuck!
Jack: *laughs*
Ken: Knock dat ass!
Mark: Oh yeah! You make daddy a go!
Jack: I'ma grind your face on a train
Mark: Ahh! Oh jeez!
Felix: And the winner is..
Felix: CinnamonToastKen!
Mark: *laughs*
Ken: CinnamonToastKen. No Jack- don't do it!
Jack: Get over here bitches!
Felix: Let's get him all down, let's get Ken down
Mark: Come on, come on, come on!
Mark: Come on guys, come on guys!
Mark: Boys! Stop fighting for 1 second- come on boys!
Ken: Dad!
Ken: Oh Jack why?!
Mark: Oh jeez!
Felix: Let go of my fuckin' eye dude!
Mark: *laughs*
Mark: Oh my God!
Felix: Jesus!
Jack: The fuck?!
Jack: HELP!
Mark: Nope stay down here, stay down-
Mark: Oh jeez!
Mark: YEAH!
Mark: How do I win?
Jack: Why did I die? I'm still over there!
Mark: How did I win? *in a creepy changing pitch*
Mark: Oh whatawala
Jack: Mark's character looks like what Ken's character tryin' to avoid!
Mark: *laughs*
Ken: Let's become a human centipede
Mark: Hey...hey!
Ken: Yeah!
Mark: How do I- how do I flop?
Jack: Hold your right face *Muffled*
Mark: Heh..
Mark: Heh!
Mark: Can I be cool like you kids here?
Mark: Ehh!
Jack: Hold B!
Mark: Eheh! Eh- eh!
Felix: Eh- ha! Dad!
Mark: Ehha ha ha ha
Mark: Hi guys- No! Stay down, stay down, stay down
Jack: *screams*
Mark: Oh hoho
Felix: Come on!
Mark: Yay!
Mark: I like this game!
Mark: Fuck off!
All: *an assortment of grunts and yells*
Mark: Fuck off, fuck off- fuck off!
Felix: Got 'em!
Jack: OH
Ken: Shit!
Mark: *laughs*
Mark: Woah! AW! My face!
Mark: I'm okay! Fuck you!
Jack: Fuck!
Mark: Fuck you!
Jack: Heh!
Mark: Hyah!
Mark: AWW!
Jack: *laughs*
Felix: Stop headbutting Jack!
Mark: Jesus!
Mark: AHHHH!
Mark: Hyep! No- no- no no
Mark: Oh how are you alive?!
Mark: What?!
Jack: WHAT?!
Ken: Yeah!
Mark: How?!
Ken: Yes!
Jack: Save me Ken!
Mark: Oh God, oh God- oh God!
Jack: Yes!
Jack: AHH FUCK!
Mark: Ehh!
Ken: Grab my hand!
Mark: Please?!
Mark: Get up heh-
Mark: *muah muah*
Mark: I just want tender kiss before we die
Mark: Please?! Please?
Mark: *muah muah*
Jack: NO!
Mark: *laughs*
Mark/Jack: *laughs*
Mark: OH My God! *laughs*
Felix: -onest Jack! Jesus Christ!
Mark: *laughs*
Ken: Ma eyesight isn't good as it used be
Ken: See if it has Mark!
Mark: *sniffs*
Mark: Na man! You have a few cavities in there!
Mark: *sniffs again*
Mark: You need to get filled!
Felix: Oh!
Mark: Let me help you with that!
Jack: Murtos Furta
Mark: *mumbles*
Ken: Shet!
Felix: Morfus forta
Mark: *the pure sound of struggle*
Ken: AHH!
Mark: *laughs*
Jack: Come here you fitta!
Felix: HEEEYYY!
Mark: Eluhk!
Jack: Javla fitta- tora
Felix: Af!
Ken: Oh yeah the ass- uhmm..
Jack: Come here!
Mark: Uhmm.. *sniffs*
Mark: Hey ya how are you?!
Ken: -ested there yeah!
Mark: *laughs*
Felix: Brofist me- brofist me!
Jack: Helveta!
Ken: Almost got it!
Mark: Ah oh aoha!
Ken: There.. Yeah!
Ken: Got it!
Mark: I know you can get it free
Mark: Oh o
Felix: Oh o!
Felix: *laughs*
Mark/Felix/Ken: YEEEYY!!
Mark: Alright fuck you guys!
Jack: I'm the only one in the track! What-
Mark/Ken: *laughs*
Jack: Dammit!
Mark: Jack are you still alive? Are you dead Jack?
Mark: You're dead!
Jack: -the door!
Mark/Ken: JAAAACKKK!!!
Mark: Jack take my hand!
Mark: Take my hand!
Ken: Oh shit!
Mark: Jack!
Jack: I can't get off
Mark: Jack! ughh!
Mark: Ehh!
Mark: Uhh!
Mark: I'll just drag you off into the of-screen here.. Don't mind me
Jack: I'm dead
Mark: Oh o!
Jack: There's no more! I'm dead!
Ken: Oh!
Mark: Oh well, we're on own now
Jack: Where's Felix?
Ken: Felix where are you?
Ken: Now there's goes Jack!
Mark: *laughs*
Ken: All over the place!
Felix: Oh!
Jack: I'm back! Bitches!
Mark/Jack: *laughs*
Mark: *gibberish*
Jack: Wait.. Am I alive?
All: WOOOAAHH!
Mark: WHATT! *laughs*
Mark: With the epic corpse take down!
(slowmo recap)
Felix: Oh man!
Mark: Oh je- oh!
Felix: Try and not fight in the beginning, I wanna do some.. Truck jumping
Mark: Okay
Felix: If you guys are up for it
Mark: Yeah yeah yeah.. Absolutely
Ken: SHIT
Ken: There's a mob of people!
Mark: Oh shit
Mark: Well they're dead..
Mark: Well- well they're out of it now
Mark: Alright, then!
Ken: Oh yea daddy!
Mark: I'ma go for it!
Jack: We win!
Mark: Here we go
Jack: This is our superhero da-
Mark: HUH! I made it!
Mark: Yeah!
Felix: Oh looks like you boys are in trouble!
[game] *puff*
Mark: Oh God! *laughs*
Felix: YEA!
Ken: You waited the whole time? *laughs*
Felix: *laughs*
Jack: Let those guys-
Mark: Yea there gonna fight it out
Mark: Woah! Go guys! Go
Jack: Wait this one we have to jump
Mark: Oh o!
Ken: Fuck you! Fuck you!
Jack: Wait this one we have to jump
Ken: That's right bea- biaaa..
Jack: Get ready to jump
Mark: Hang on, we have to jump? How can you tell?
Mark: AH!
Mark: Oh! Jesus!
Jack: Stupid lag!
Felix: YEA!
Ken: *laughs*
Felix: Yea- NO!
Mark: *laughs*
Felix: WOOOAAH!
Jack: Felix!
Felix: Fucking hell
Mark: Alright
Mark: Hey (x1)
Mark: Hey (x2)
Mark: Hey (x3)
Mark: Hey (x4)
Mark: Hey (x5)
Mark: Hey (x6)
Jack: Hey Ken!
Ken: Yea
Ken: How you doin' Jack!
Mark: Alright I'ma make this- jump
Jack: Hold on Ken
Mark: ROOROROOF!
Mark: Yea!
Ken: I'm griping
Mark: Hey!
Felix: Oh dammit
Ken: There's no driver in here
Mark: Wait what?!
Felix: I got it
Mark: AHHH! Oh God!
Felix: *laughs*
Ken: Mark NOOO!
Mark: Oh jeez.. *laughs*
Ken: EH!
Mark: You guys are doin' so good
Jack: Eh!
Ken: Jack!
Jack: No- no- no
Ken: Jack, you the superhero I'll let you go..
Jack: AHHHHH!
Mark: *laughs*
Ken: Ah were fucked
Felix: Let go of my-
Mark: Hey Jack! Hey!
Mark: Hey
Jack: Hey
Mark: He- hey!
Ken: Get dat ass Jack
Mark: NNOOOONOO!
Felix: I made it in!
Jack: Someone's gonna give up, you've been holding longer than I have
Mark: AH My diaper
Mark: My diaper!
Ken: *laughs*
Ken: Oh you jump out
Jack: AHH!
Mark: *laughs*
Ken: Wait I think Felix is still inside the truck
Mark: Wait what?!
Ken: *laughs*
Mark: I'm gettin' in the truck
Felix: I'm driving the truck guys!
Mark: Woah
Felix: Oh how did you survived that
Jack: How did you do that
Mark: I dunno. Hop!
[game] *puff*
All: *laughs*
Felix: AWW!
Mark: HEEHH! Everybody fightin' so goooood..
Mark: YEheheya
Mark: Woah o!
Mark: Oh my God
Ken: Ah my head!
Mark: You alright?
Mark: Oh jeez
Mark: AHH!
Mark: Don't kill me
Mark: Hug!
Mark: Hug
Felix: AHH!
Mark: Woahoho
Mark: Hug
Mark: Huuuuggggg.. Hug!
Felix: NO!
Mark: Hug (x1)
Mark: Hug (x2)
Mark: Hug (x3)
Mark: AH- ah! Oh God!
Jack: *laughs*
Mark: *laughs*
Mark: Oops I've fallin' Ohh!
Mark: Ohhhe- hey
Jack: We don't have an HR manager so I can't do anything
Mark: I can't do.. anythiiinng..
Mark: Ah shit goddamit
Ken: Mark! Noooo!
Mark: Ahh! Boink!
Mark: Hang on wait!
Felix: I'm tryin' to save you guys
Mark: Hum.. I got it! Hang on
Ken: Take my tits!
Mark: Shit- shit! Ah fuck
Ken: Oh no
Mark: Hey I'm alive!
Mark: I made it.. woah *laughs*
Mark: Yea!
Jack: Oh yea baby! Oh-
Jack: I'm gonna eat dat ass tho
Ken: Oh face first! dat ass
Mark: Hmmm..
Jack: Eat dat ass boi
Mark: Don't mind me- don't mind me
Mark: I just want to be part of it.. are you cool kids over here
Mark: *laughs*
Mark: Hey- hey- hey- hey!
Ken: Shit- jousting!
Ken: Oh- oh!
Mark: *laughs*
Jack: Grab the nipple
Felix: Oh!
Mark: *laughs*
Mark: Yeah! Ahh!
Mark: Oh o! Wait!
Ken: Ah my ti..
Ken: *laughs*
Jack: Oh o!
Mark: Hoho Ahaa
Mark: Losers!
Jack: How do you get back up?
Ken: *laughs*
Mark: Eh hoho
Mark: Look at my hair flop
Ken: He moves his hair back 'n forth.. ah!
Mark: Felix ya-
Jack: AHH!
Mark: Wow!
Mark: You 'right here Felix?
Felix: Fuck you up.. oh yea
Mark: Hang on- no- no I want it- no- I want it oho
Felix: What the fuck happened there?!
Mark: I saw that!
Mark/Ken: *laughs*
Jack: Have you got worms Felix?
Mark: Hey Ken
Mark: What you doin'
Mark: *laughs*
Ken: Oh yea!
Felix: Let me get in on this guys
Ken: Woah- hoho
Mark: Heh
Ken: Party!
Mark: I'm just like Miley!
Ken: AH!
Mark: Oh you kids!
Mark: Daddy knows how to twerk! Don't even be mistaken
Ken: Oh yea!
Mark: Yeah!
Felix: You like that!
Mark: Oh yea
Mark: Oh *french laugh*
Mark: Oh oh!
Felix: Oh oh
Mark: Hya!
Felix: Fuck Septiplier
Jack: *laughs*
Mark: *laughs*
Jack: Pewdieplier is real! *Laughs*
Mark: Aw! Don't grab my mustache
Ken: Oh yea!
Mark: *struggling*
Mark: Oh Jezus!
Felix: Gonna sample that grunting Mark and have it for my ringtone
Ken: Oh no- don't make me do it! OHH!
Mark: *laughs*
Felix: Oh my God!
Mark: Felix wa- walk away- just walk away
(Ken makes sexual grunting sounds)
Mark: *laughs*
Ken: Yea I did it!
Mark: Short quick thrust is all it takes!
Jack: ppprrrra!
Mark: *laughs*
Mark: Like a machine gun
Mark: I'm ending this- I can't live
Mark: I can't live this way
Mark: Oh- Haha!
Jack/Mark: *laughs*
Jack: You went out like you lived like a hero!
Mark: Thanks man!
Mark: *laughs*
(outro)